alle mein name ist überlebenszeit bei
paok frühestens in der asse begrüßt dass
sie voll verändert ja freunde
bildschirmhintergrund ich bin ich sage
immer ihr seht schon im hintergrund
nicht ob ihr könnt selber sehen dass ich
gerade nicht bei mir zu hause sondern
bei meiner familie oder und hier nämlich
eigentlich war nur ihr live videos auf
ein gaming pc cetera ja in meiner
wohnung steht ich will da gerade frisch
zurückgekommen aus berlin wir noch ein
bisschen heiser vom fußballgucken
rumschreien et cetera pp wir waren ja in
seinem schloss
sorry dass ich diese szenen vor dem
schloss oft 14 und das video so auf der
vene aber ich fand es einfach ultra
ultra holt raten eis aber ja da habe ich
mir heute gedacht okay was nämlich auf
oder ist mit den sinn gekommen dass ihr
immer kommentare videos richtig feiert
das ist irgendwie ich beantworte böse
kommentare oder ich beantworte fragen
von euch oder ich lese nur ein paar
kommentare unter dem letzten video vor
was viel diskutiert wurde habe ich jetzt
einfach mal gedacht ich nehme jetzt ein
paar kommentare raus jetzt nicht
unbedingt unter einem bestimmten video
geschrieben wurden sondern halt unter
den letzten drei vier fünf videos immer
warum vermehren aufgetaucht sind und die
mich so ein bisschen einerseits ab
fakten andererseits wo ich gern mal
darauf antworten würde andererseits
coole kommentare dumme witzige
kommentare fallen direkt mit mehreren
kommentar luca mach bitte mehr solcher
videos macht echt bock bei sowas
zuzusehen tüte popcorn lukas video eine
pizza oder kühle kopf der abend läuft
due to an sich habe ich da gar nichts
gegen einen kommentar einzuwenden der
ist ultra coole leute die mir den durch
leser dachte okay dass die wirklich
einer dass wir punkte das ist ein
impulsiver erneute schreiben die häufig
was zu essen und zu trinken wirklich ein
video von mir anzuschauen das heißt halt
so als würde man so in etwa von kino für
design ich meine im kino holt man sich
auch was zu essen und zu trinken und
guckt sich dann den film an so als
großes ereignis okay ich nehme immer
essen und trinken direkt mit ins kino
was ich vorher am kiosk gekauft habe
allerdings ein kommentar an sich ganz
doch dann schreit der könnt ihr einen
kanal banner bewerten nicht brauche
feedback dass das ist nämlich genau die
art von kommentaren die ich über alles
hasse vor allen dingen wie will man
kanal bader bewerten ist gefällt mir auf
dem bagger oder war das sind diese
typischen spam werbung kommentare dies
derzeit auf youtube gibt die halt
einfach so aufgebaut sind 90 prozent
sind ja geil das video hat mir echt
gefallen die stelle dabei einer minute
43 die er wahrscheinlich nicht mal
gesehen hat seine zahlreichen streiks
das stimme aber ja wie gesagt ich bin
heiser
der hauptteil des kommentars irgendwas
er dachtest was immer kopiert wird von b
geiles video cooler kanal finden content
echt klasse l ticker direkt mit tüten
flaschen chips nehmen und um ein golf
cart nase lang und er ist irgendwie
umgefallen und danach kommt immer am
abschluss schaut doch mal bei mir vorbei
bewertet auch ein kanal wanner geht doch
war noch meinen kanal nein nein ich habe
mich dann an die hätte ich will doch nur
kommentare sie konstruktiv sind die sich
auf das video beziehen bitte freunde
warum können nicht mal kommentare kommen
die ja luca korrekt ein bisschen weiter
runter oder hier macht doch mal
schwarz-weiß oder macht noch mal mehr
traurige musik oder kompass immer die
traurige musik wäre ich will kommentar
an dem man sich verbessern kann und
nicht sonnenschein also diese t-shirts
haben keinen stil können die nicht mehr
etwas anständiges anziehen
dieser kommentare unter dem video was
ich mit paddy hochgeladen habe das war
so eine basketball challenge und diese
kommentare schreiberin beschwert sich
über unsere t-shirts sie hatten ein
blaues und ein weißes t shirt an seinem
anzug ein basketballkorb abwerfen sollte
sich ein kleiner anziehen oder was
ich mag die nicht wer schaut dieses
video mit socken an sorry luca aber die
abo der awo drückst du mit dem schalter
habe ich zu abonnieren oder was ich weiß
nicht was man gegen kelly haben kann für
mich ist berlin absoluter sonnenschein
und ein ultra nettes mädchen und ich
feiere ihren content komplett also sagte
nichts gegen kelly und kam mir irgend
einer sagen wieso unter meinen videos so
oft dieses wert dieses video mit socken
an oder auch unter anderem youtube video
sie so dazu oft geschrieben wird wen
interessiert versucht diesen kommentar
auf einer geraden zahl zu halten ist
halt auch wieder so ein typischer
kommentar von wegen ich denke was
kreatives ausland statt zu schreiben
geht mir bitte like seine stimme ist
irgendwie komplett beim durchrollen
dachte ich mir dann halt so jo ok wi fi
alliance wird er darauf wohl haben
vielleicht ziehen allerhöchstens einem
guten tag 11 an seinem geburtstag 6 12
oder seinem die leute aus mitleid normal
icon oder sich ja die like sein und
dieses 361 3 161 300 wie dieses video
auch ohne sockel cook teil sind doch ein
verdammtes maulen windows ist er doch
ist mit produkt- oder nicht
um das ganze jetzt mal zu beenden mit
dieser scheiß sorgten sache schreiten
wir jetzt in die kommentare guck dir das
video mit socken oder ohne socken und
dann nur dieses video schreiben und ab
dann bitte nie wieder jetzt hinschreiben
jetzt sagen guckt jetzt mit socken guckt
jetzt ohne seine riesige sorgten
unterhaltung alles gut die ganzen sorgen
wie die kisten sind abgehakt und danach
können wir bitte alles vergessen
danke super cool der nächste kommentare
ein komplettes beispiel dafür dass sich
die youtube kommentare komplett
verabscheue like du gewinnst morgen im
lotto aber du bekommst das schönste
mädchen der welt ignorieren du willst
dass alle neugeborenen sterben ja also
ich habe ihn nicht abonniert das heißt
es ich bekomme nicht das schönste
mädchen der welt das ist das ist sehr
traurig herr kollege wie heißer
gerüchteküche er bettelt küche oder so
er hat halt auch 189 leicht auf dem
kommentar ich weiß nicht ob sich da
leute hoch lag mit irgendwelchen bots
verletzten hatte mir kollegen von meinem
netzwerk sagt jutta guckst du deine
kommentare an das sind 10 kommentare
topf kommen ist mit über 1000 like die
ihnen die werbung für ihren channels
machen zeichnet euch durch content aus
durch dadurch dass ihr irgendwie aus
rassen dadurch dass ihr euch gut
schminken können dadurch dass ihr zocken
können oder dadurch dass ihr nicht
zocken können aber es irgendwie witzig
darstellen irgendwas aber hört auf mit
den kommentaren und dich das einzige was
ich will sind konstruktive kommentare
konstruktive kritik nette kommentare
eine gute community und in den
kommentaren und was kommt solche miss
gestalten wie ihr was away diese
kommentare scheiße bei youtube ist echt
so am arsch visa und freundlich den
beiden video auf was auf meinem kann
alles verändern wird mit super
bewertungen kommentare resonanzen
reaktionen et cetera das wird bald
kommen ich warte auf den richtigen
moment ab ist es bei mir so ich warte
noch auf den tropfen der das fass zum
überlaufen bringt seit wann komme ich
auch so tolle wortspiele look oder guck
das auch über dem challenge wieder was
ich mit kelly aufgenommen haben sich in
paaren shipping namen überlegt look kann
ich ja noch verstehen dass es irgendwie
so luca und kelly aber guck also kelly
ist drin das kac ich als luca nicht luca
diese war schon gestern nicht in der
schule
mein vater ist im krankenhaus sieben
tage später ist dein vater noch immer im
krankenhaus ja erst arzt leicht wenn
noch keine ferien hat bei 200 leicht
oder 3000 sexuell abonnenten gehen wir
zu einem polizisten und frankie mit
einer fake waffe zu dir will ich gar
nicht das sagen was ich gerade schon
gesagt habe allerdings bitte verpiss
dich von meinem kanal und auch alle
anderen range was die mining welche
beamten zu bringen es gab ja schon mal
vor einiger zeit dass das jemand in die
kommentare von mir geschrieben hat wir
schreiben des tores beim 1
dann ging das irgendwie über 200
kommentare wurde geschichte geschrieben
das sind auch wiederum coole kommentare
sowas wurde jetzt wieder veranstaltet
und zwar jemand geschrieben es war
einmal ein luca und darauf kam dann
direkt die antwort der hatte fake kuba
das sind den fake huber ich meine letzte
geschichte ging ihnen die sojus war
einmal in luca de ging im fall der treff
gehen dieser hatte das gemacht da was
gefunden da was gilt gelingt hier und
jetzt dies war der hatte fake kuba wenn
du noch mal so was macht die abo ehre
dich auch danke für dein sehr cooles
statement unter meinem video zu haben
also wenn ich mein content derzeit stört
kann ich dir wirklich auch nur ans herz
legen ja einfach zu gehen und wären wir
auch schon am anfang klar dass luca uns
wieder verarscht das war unter dem video
wo ich euch mein schloss gezeigt habe
natürlich war von anfang an klar ich hab
schon so oft in videos gesagt dass ich
euch nie irgendwie meine komplette
wohnung oder so zeigen werde höchstens
vielleicht mal bilder kommentieren aus
der wohnung raus oder so was in die
richtung oder sich direkt im video raus
wo ich einmal genau das mache und
andererseits sagen dass sie vergeblich
ein haus bzw
ein schloss gekauft habe also ich meine
natürlich war es klar aber es haben auch
wieder folgen viele leute geglaubt und
mich danach erhält also ich weiß nicht
aber es ist auch irgendwie witzig was
ich allerdings nicht gedacht hätte war
das der kommentar ab 265 lions hat also
das 865 leute sagen ja
mir war es direkt von anfang an klar
dass du konstant war das was mit dem
video meine damen und herren es euch
gefallen hat freue ich mich über eine
bewährte und bitte das wirklich meine
bewertung da weil wir solche videos
extrem viel spaß machen und die sehen
will ob es euch gefällt oder nicht ich
will sollte einfach mal auf ein paar
kommentare eingegangen die mich total
ist ab fakten nämlich diese ganze
werbung scheiße getan als irgendwas ganz
tolles oder dazu noch ein paar fragen
beantwortet deswegen weil ich bin auf
ein paar andere kommentare eingegangen
ich hoffe das war irgendwie cool und wir
sehen uns dann morgen wieder